But the Have you seen the latest
problems and issues with Christian
Zionist and what set Satan now who said
and how these Zionist dogs wanted to
then defend and excuse what he said
about our Lord Jesus Christ?
So I called it out
on
Twitter. Let me go there and show you.
Right here. Again,
pray that I become a man of integrity
and not prostitute myself
and not be controversial for the sake of
controversy cuz they're already starting
the lies that were anti-Semitic.
Right?
Anti-Semitic.
Now notice this clown trying to say the
Pope was wrong. I know.
Let me just say it.
Because I just want to say this.
Yep.
Your facts
checked.
Yeah, see?
In the first century scholars will tell
you
that the Jews spoke Aramaic. So Aramaic
was called Hibraisti Hibraisti cuz it
was considered the dialect of the Jews.
Okay?
So you have another Zionist pig who's
saying
no, uh the Pope is wrong. Jesus spoke
Hebrew. Get any good commentary.
Don't don't take my word for it. Right?
Paul could read Hebrew, but they spoke
Aramaic. That was the dialect of the
Jews and further proof of it is if you
look even the Talmud is in Aramaic.
And then they produced
paraphrase Old Testament in Aramaic.
Right? But here's the controversy. And
again, I'm going to call out
this Zionist pig.
I don't know how you Orthodox are
letting him become Orthodox.
Okay?
He tries to excuse and defend his
master,
Satan Netanyahu.
And someone said, "See, you're
anti-Semitic." No, you're
anti-Christian, you fake. That's not
going to work.
Trying to scare us with that label
doesn't work.
Right? Now watch here. I'm going to have
to call it out, man. Look at here.
This out of Look at this dog.
This out of context clip only shows
that Netanyahu views Jesus as
representative of goodness. You see what
a dog he is?
You're telling me this guy's not
compromised?
May the Lord Jesus rebuke him and David
Wood, his enabler, to repent and fear
God and destroy their cult of
personality. They're both dogs.
Why?
Satan Netanyahu said that Jesus's
teachings are no better than Genghis
Khan.
And he blames it on Will Durant. But by
quoting Will Durant, that means he
agrees with Will Durant. So they're
going into damage control. These pigs
who claim to be Christian.
Orthodox, reach
out to his Eastern Orthodox church. Tell
the priest to rebuke him and stop him
until he repents. He's a Zionist lover.
He is. It's disgusting.
Let me show you what he said in context.
Here's the context. Now you tell me if
anything changes. 100 page.
>> [clears throat]
>> Also wrote the lessons of history.
Very 100 page. I can't even hear it.
Let's see if I can find it.
>> Also wrote the lessons of history. Also
Also wrote the lessons of history.
>> This is how This is as loud as it gets.
See if you can hear.
Also wrote the lessons History,
very brief, 100-page book. 100-page
book.
>> in which he said,
"Well, history proves
that
unfortunately and unhappily,
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan."
Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan, and these Zionist dogs are
trying to
defend it saying, "Well, he was quoting
Will Durant."
Now, glory to Jesus Christ for this
Palestinian Lutheran pastor
who was interviewed by Tucker Carlson
and called out the atrocities of
Netanyahu and the IDF.
How do you defend this? And you see what
that dog Rizwan said? That only shows
That only shows
Now, look at this dog, David Wood.
Stop embarrassing yourself.
Who you He uses as an example somebody
supremely good. You see this dog? You're
a dog, David. God rebuke you. You're a
disgusting pig.
And he's telling the Palestinian
Lutheran pastor,
"Stop embarrassing himself." You see
these dogs? Cuz his lover, apostate
prophet,
said the same thing. David, I hope your
cult follower,
Jinjjat, tells you you are a disgusting
dog.
You filth.
Right?
You're saying, "Jesus didn't bring some
goodness by saying no advantage over
Genghis Khan."
And you guys still support these dogs?
That's David Wood who blocked me cuz
he's a coward.
He doesn't like it when you call out
this bully and put him in his place. You
wicked dog. You're disgusting, man. You
really are. May the Lord teach you his
fear and rebuke you and destroy your
cult following and you repent.
The coward cuz he can't handle it when
people stand up to him block me cuz
you're a coward. You're not a man.
Filthy coward.
And I love what this guy said. David
respectfully, the only one constantly
embarrassing himself is you with your
dozens of copy pasted texts.
Right?
On every post calling out this evil
being, you show up to defend him with
the same Sorry, that's what he
said.
Did you get your $7,000? Are you really
just that naive? I don't know.
See? No, he didn't, David.
He tried to degrade Jesus as God in the
flesh
by comparing
Here, let me just say it.
Right?
Zionist sorry. I'm sorry, I'm not.
Zionist lover.
Sorry.
For defending
this insult of our Lord.
And you guys still want to support him,
huh? Because you guys are all jokes,
too.
Cult of personality. I I didn't even
know this. Filthy vile lowlife that you
would protect this.
Right?
So, let me show you
Let me So you can hear it. Sorry, guys.
I have to call this out. So, I'm not
going to be liked. I'm not going to be
popular. I'm going to be disliked, but
pray I'm a man of integrity. God save me
from my flesh and sin not hand me over
cuz I'm not going to be platformed. I'm
not going to be liked. I won't have many
numbers.
Now, watch the difference between these
Zionist dogs, David Wood an apostate
prophet,
with this independent fundamental
Baptist preacher,
King James only independent
fundamentalist Baptist preacher who
thinks we're all going to hell.
Catholics are dogs. But look at his
boldness. Look.
Let me show you.
Look at the difference between this guy
and hideous wood, Zionist dog. Look.
proves
that
unfortunately and unhappily
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan.
He says unfortunately. Because if you
are strong enough, ruthless enough,
powerful enough
evil will overcome good.
David wants to defend us. Stop burying
yourself saying Jesus supremely good.
But your master, you filthy dog, said
there is no advantage of what Jesus said
over Genghis Khan. Unfortunately. Even
says it's unfortunate.
What's unfortunate? That Jesus said turn
the other cheek?
Right? Do not repay evil with evil?
That's unfortunate?
And you're going to liken Jesus' words
to Genghis Khan?
And David wants to defend us.
Filthy lowlife.
Filthy lowlife, man. And you guys
encourage this?
He's a cult leader. He's no better him
and apostate prophet than the Muslim
Dawa gangs he condemns. Cuz he justifies
what an adulterer is doing, not calling
him repentance. So how much better are
you than from Muhammad Ajab, your Muslim
counterpart, you dog?
You are a dog, dude. Aggression will
overcome moderation. James 2:7 says, "Do
not they blaspheme that worthy name by
which you are called?" A question to the
Christians out there.
Why halt ye between two opinions? How do
you continue to support a nation whose
leader
blasphemes
our God? Wow. And which you
Independent fundamental Baptist
King James only who thinks the Catholics
or Orthodox going to hell cuz we don't
have the gospel.
Shh, rebuking us, putting us to shame.
Yeah, don't use Satan Yahoo cuz Yahoo is
God's name. Put neton put set Satan
Yahoo, Satan Yahoo.
Filthy pig, David. I didn't know you
would bark like that, but you're a
coward, dude.
That's it. I'm going to be calling him a
dog from now on. Not a general, you're a
general of Satan, you
filthy pig.
Now watch it again. Listen. She said,
"Well, history proves that
unfortunately and unhappily
uh Jesus Christ has no advantage over
Genghis Khan."
What did this pig say?
>> Because if you are strong enough,
ruthless enough, powerful enough,
evil will overcome good.
Aggression will overcome moderation.
James 2:7 says, "Do not they blaspheme
that worthy name by which you're
called?" A question to the
>> Christians out there,
why halt ye between two opinions? How do
you continue to support a nation whose
leader blasphemes
our God? Uh and what he said,
"Well, history proves
Will Durant. Now, let's see what David
Wood said again, these two dogs, and you
wonder why I'm getting angry?
And he's actually
attacking
this man,
David Wood, the dog is attacking someone
here, Isaac,
a Lutheran pastor in Palestine,
who was interviewed about the atrocities
committed against Palestinians
And what does that dog say?
What did he say? Watch here. What did
David Wood say, the dog?
Because his master was attacked. You see
You see it, right?
Unbelievable.
Unbelievable. I didn't even know that.
Honestly, I didn't know that.
I swear I didn't know it.
I had no idea that he had chimed in.
Vile dog.
David was another vile filthy dog and
sellout.
May Lord Jesus rebuke and bring a sign
of his love and for defending the self
of our Lord.
See?
I had no idea. I swear I swear.
It took this guy Paulo. God bless you,
brother.
Proud of you, Paulo, for calling him
out.
Proud of you.
You guys disgust me when you follow cult
of personality and then you still give
these dogs a platform.
Ginja, you are also an effeminate
disgusting cult follower.
May your wife beat you into manhood
verbally and spiritually. Stop
being a cult follower, you sellout.
You guys are all sellouts, man.
Seriously. Anyway, sorry, guys. I had to
vent. I didn't know that. I just got
angry. You're seeing it live.
All right. So, expect Satan Nahu, man,
not Satan Yahoo. Yahoo is God's name.
Put Satan Nahu.